what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time
well while she's trying to get rich to
us unless is trying to get a lunch money
right I'm here by myself
without playing Oh plenty is digitally
available the beautiful intelligent
Panamera Nova
don't forget unless money's not smashed
by block 5 go to block 5 comm slash
lunch money get money get paid eight
point six percent interest on more
deposits in your interest-bearing
account you can also deposit crypto and
get a u.s. dollar loan
yo Paulina what up what up how is my
kitchen doing is it your kitchen or my
kitchen or is it both of our kitchens
Hey I feel like learn I feel like when I
yell yo Paulina it's like when Rocky's
in the boxing ring and he's like yo
Adrian like yo Paulina what's that movie
because you came from a different
country and you hate American culture
it's fine what's going on with dead
stimulus alright the feds sent one point
four billion dollars in stimulus checks
to more than a million deceased people
and basically what happened was that the
Treasury doesn't talk to the Social
Security office so they like didn't have
the people who died the list of people
who died thought take that's not that
much money
1.4 million sounds cream yeah well point
four billion sounds crazy but it was a
million people had died and they didn't
know about it out of the more than three
hundred billion they sent it's like 30
basis points of the money ended up going
to dead people I bet you that they sent
more people more money to people
fraudulently like people who were
committing fraud than they did dead
people so like a billion sound bad but
after the 300 billion something like 30
his points I actually would have guessed
that'd be higher still I think they
should have done better and not muddled
the job like they did I agree I
definitely agree do you sure done oh I
do I sure know what are you talking
about all right I just didn't know all
right that's fine
dead stimulus they got people what would
you say the day what nothing okay
lemonade ready hey guys I'm in trouble
that means I'm in trouble don't worry
she can't get me haha
what's going on with lemonade Softbank
backed lemonade the insurance company
wants to raise up to two hundred and
eighty six million dollars in an IPO
which were value it at about 25 percent
less than its latest funding round what
do we think I read the s-1 the entire
s-1 I read it he did I was there I'm
bullish on lightning they're busy using
technology to attack the industry
vertical and what they're able to do by
using technology as they get customers
earlier when they're younger and they
have small dollars so you buy you know
ten $20 a month policies and then as you
get older you just stay with them so the
LTV or the lifetime value grows and
grows and grows and so the acquisition
cost is very low for somebody that ends
up staying with you and you get more and
more of their wallet share over time and
the fact that they're using technology
means that they can actually have a
deflationary impact on the business
model so costs go down and what's
interesting is it's still insurance so
it's a great business in general right
of insurance and then on top of all of
that they've also backstopped I think
was 75% of claims with reinsurance so
they are not even holding the actual
liability so it's a pretty interesting
model in terms of using technology to
disrupt a known existing good business
and also you're have some very
interesting unit economics to acquire
customers much earlier in the life
cycle and as they get older you get more
and more revenue from them do we care
that in the private markets it was
valued as high as two billion and now
it's gonna have a market cap of around
1.3 billion no it just means that the
private markets were inflated which is
pretty obvious right like yeah there was
a bunch of frothy miss but like it
probably also means that this is more
like the real that they actually
compared to what's going on the private
market so the one people who get screwed
are the private market investors who
bought the top right everyone else is
right so basically if you're rich what
would you buy some stock ah I don't buy
stock all right by the way when you
smack your lips we can hear it real loud
on the recording I'm great okay
that's the point why don't you why don't
I buy it yeah cuz I don't buy it no
stocks
ah smart lady Di's tomorrow lady I was
going with Albertsons
so the u.s. supermarket operator
Albertsons decided to go ahead with a
downsized 800 million dollar IPO on
Thursday so that's some another IPO in
2020 data is kind of missing its targets
just reality ma'am world's changed can't
be bringing them inflated ass valuations
into the public markets or you get get
shot by the public market investors
right but do we think that these
companies would have gone like if if it
wasn't for the pandemic and they had
gone public as scheduled in 2020 under
normal circumstances they wouldn't have
to downsize if it wasn't for the
pandemic of course but the pandemic
drove asset prices down right so like
there's plenty of companies where their
stock price is down so you could make
the argument
they've gone public beforehand they
would still be at the same valuation
that they're going public at now because
it would have just dropped it up in the
public markets some people would argue
that if they hadn't gotten public it
might actually have inflated but who
knows so why don't they just wait until
like 2021 or something they probably
need the money but I mean that's one
that's one reason another is they
actually may think that now's a good
time for some reason like grocery stores
are hot or something right in terms of
their pandemic proof something like that
I don't know got it you're my hair you
Wow another haircut you have great
lighting though I will say I never
appreciated the lighting of the kitchen
until now when I don't have it like so a
nice it is your skin is glowing today
glowing the pandemic just what you look
just as pretty as I do yeah I heard it I
just wanted you to say it again but like
I think it looked prettier than you do
you look just as pretty as I do go ahead
what's going on with chococheese the
pandemic has come for the one and only
chuck-e-cheese it's filing for
bankruptcy after 47 years of
remember what y'all was all saying that
bitcoin was going to zero and oil never
would remember when y'all was calling
chuck-e-cheese coins will the pandemic
bra oil negative prices and it bankrupt
chuck-e-cheese and bitcoin still here
baby
okay so enlisted nearly two billion
dollars in debt and 1.7 billion in
assets and its bankruptcy petition so
it's just gonna read I think it's gonna
restructure of course it has to equity
gets wiped out they'll get new owners
and they'll move on but I bet you chuck
e cheese is owned by a private equity
firm right yeah it almost guaranteed it
is
yeah cuz what private equity owners
would be dumb enough to lever up a
company with 1.8 billion dollars in
assets with 2 billion dollars of debt
and they probably sucked all the about
the value out of it like vultures and
left yeah he's like that it's owned by
Apollo Global Management massive firm
come on Apollo got rich and chunky
cheese got sent to bankruptcy court it's
nonsense
yes it costs coming out of this crisis
go ahead what's going on angle Google
will start paying some publishers to
license their news articles what do you
think mr. journalist well I think I
think this is nothing new I think
Facebook has been doing it for a while
now it's about time Google does it I
guess if you're gonna license somebody's
content you have to pay them for it I
just don't think it's a good idea for
media companies to be reliant on the
revenue from big tech firms they cover
that I agree
how can you actively cover Google when
did your revenue source
nobody's objective in this world but I
agree generally that it's a bad idea to
become dependent on the big evil Google
I actually don't think Google's even
evil but I like to give him a hard time
that they removed the motto of don't be
evil ok was that I was ready that was
was that like you're not funny but I'm
trying to be nice yes that is exactly
what that was by the way my lighting is
great but their lamp that it looks like
you turned on there is shining off the
side of your head ok he's pretty as I do
okay with Ron James LeBron James is
raised has raised a hundred million
dollars for a new media company
alongside maverick Carter his agent and
they're gonna launch the media company
featuring african-american content
creators geared toward the community so
that's interesting I think about these
like what I don't think it's new
Springhill entertainment is the name of
it has been around for a while they've
produced a bunch of shows like the show
in the barber shop and a bunch of other
things I think they've been working on
it for a while mmm it has like a hundred
yeah I think that the more story that
the more stories we can bring from
different voices the better I'm all
about just I want to hear from everybody
and I want to hear everybody's
perspective I agree one hundred million
dollars baby what up LBJ the hundred
million dollar man she's my affiliate I
don't think he's a billionaire no not
yet
all right are you ready for what are we
gonna ask people to do for lunch money
this week I want people to take the
YouTube video go in the comments and
whoever leaves pulling of the nicest
comment she'll pick a winner and will
tell you on one Monday oh yeah what your
points if you say something nice about
me - okay the record I'm not doing this
this is super hard and there's a lot of
lag so cut us a break be nice to be
funny like I can keep interrupting her
right remotely like literally I could
just do it all day a lot of people last
time said they thought that we got in an
argument before lunch money but that's
that was just because I kept getting
frustrated that you were freezing I
couldn't hear you and you kept
interrupting me so NBD we're not an
argument we're just having technical
difficulties we
also you don't know this but are you
ready no I have made the executive
decision by myself that starting today
maybe tomorrow or maybe Monday maybe
every Friday maybe every day but for
today I will be ending the show with a
joke how excited are you ok so here's a
joke
why don't calculus majors throw house
parties hold on why get you have to
guess I don't know ok are you ready for
the answer why I said go ahead because
you should never drink and drive too
funny too funny anyway that's it for
today you think that's funny that's why
you're a nerd you're a nerd that joke is
funny my heart rate they'd like this it
didn't go anywhere like this not funny I
think she's all like I think people will
like and I think you are wrong I'm gonna
bring my own jokes to the show now Oh
before you bring your own jokes do you
want to tell us about our sponsor today
we already talked about them pay
attention you don't even pay attention
see this is why this show this show is
so reliant on me you may be talent with
me on the operational excellence around
here Joe and I called I think I think I
might have been frozen for that period
but ok you say so
ladies and gentlemen at home your boy is
gonna have
have a me day today I am going to drink
some lights I'm gonna order some pizza
last night I got a call from downstairs
in the lobby and they're like Paulina
you have a delivery and I was like what
delivery and they were like you have
sushi here your sushi has arrived and I
was like Anthony go pick up your sushi
that's a me day Lina's goal
abandon me and make me survive on my own
imma order out sorry I made a big mess
too but nobody can see it yeah it'll be
clean by the time you come back alright
guys that's it for lunch one day today
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
hopefully plaintiff will be back on
Monday see you guys then bang bang hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of lunch
money as much as we did don't forget
lunch money's now sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
I'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fire
than you are of me block lies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina they've got 3 products they can
give you a US dollar loan you can earn
up to eight point six percent interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell crypto currencies on
their crypto exchange I personally use
the interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playing in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends